les villes président étaient nombreux au
conseil municipal de leur commune pour
connaître enfin le dénouement de ce que
certains anciens élus de la majorité
qualifie de séisme
avec le retour du maire à la rentrée
malgré les affaires judiciaires
la majorité a explosé ce mardi 24
septembre il fallait rétablir la
situation pour un maire qui a déjà
annoncé ne pas se représenter aux
élections municipales prochaines faut
bien avoir en tête que si je
démissionnais aujourd'hui conseiller
municipal et dise où on revote et dans
quatre mois on revote je pense pas que
ce soit le mieux pour la ville je vais
décider les affaires courantes et il ya
des gros projets qui sont encore là il
faut qu'on pense à a eu un maire qui
assume l'intérim entre deux groupes
formés durant ce conseil municipal l'a
initié par sylvie ce vin montel en signe
deuxième adjointe et le groupe
villepreux d'abord avec laurent blanc
car ancien adjoint à l'activité
économique
c'est un énorme gâchis ça m'empêche pas
de penser que tout ça n'aurait jamais dû
exister
on était prêts avec une liste complète
pour 2020 tout était decker tout était
nickel il en arrive là je suis vraiment
consterné par ce qui se passe mais en
tout cas ce soir je suis soulagé pour
passer à autre chose et parler de demain
et pas de avant-hier hier et cet été la
liste a explosé en vol
c'est ce qu'eric souvent on le sait dans
beaucoup de communes celle électrique
explosions viennent l'intérieur
maintenant chacun va suivre son chemin
et on verra bien ce que ça va donner
que le meilleur gagne pour 2020 en
attendant les prochaines élections
municipales claude bertin s'est proposé
volontaire au poste de premier adjoint
au maire élu avec vingt bulletins pour 1
nul et 1 blanc il permet à la commune
d'éviter la mise sous tutelle de la
préfecture
redoutée par l'opposition mais on avait
peur d'une mise sous tutelle si y'avait
pas d'adjoint et c'est jamais bon
en fin de fin d'exercice donc voilà bon
donc on va continuer notre rôle
d'opposant maintenant il ya plusieurs
groupes donc voilà comment ça se passe
un conseil municipal qui lance les
prochaines élections avec déjà
potentiellement trois listes qui se
dégage